well I think without further ado we have
talking about large-scale training in
Verona thanks a lot for having me here
it's a great pleasure to be here at
Simon's this talk is a joint work with
the cooperate on mines over Yahoo is the
phd season of Michael as well as the
rest of palace to pitch and move Shang
you you see Chang Peter as was a people
operators from the Lord
they clean up from spiritual National
Lab - I didn't as was Michael and
coracoid they're my postdoc or
supervisor so our research is basically
the full stack of neural networks going
from finding the right neural network
architecture which requires a lot of
design space exploration and that
requires a lot of China training data
and more importantly you need to train a
lot of different networks for a
particular application very fast because
there is a lot of possible nor left with
architectures for a particular
application and that requires rapid
training and this is this will be the
focus of this talk but then there is
very interesting dependence on how do
you go all the way down to silicon
design very metal design how do you make
a hardware that is good for the poor
doing matrix multiplication it's
surprising that if you know not all
Network linear algebra and hardware you
can design more efficient hardware such
as TPU that's another very interesting
direction today I'll be focusing mainly
on rapid training of neural networks and
these are a few works that I've been
involved with over the past year there
in Berkeley along these directions so
what's the high-level outline
deep neural network design requires
training on very large data sets and
this is very time-consuming so we need
fast training methods and it's one of
the ways is to do parallel compute doing
it in distributed memory and that one of
the ways to do that is large batch size
large batch size training does not work
for a variety of reasons one of the
problems is that it degrades accuracy
it's very it exhibits poor robustness to
adversarial inputs and
listing solutions don't work what they
require massive hyper parameter tuning
you know before showing what what the
what our proposed solution is I'm going
to tell you what am I gonna show today
we're gonna show a new Hessian based
large besides training that achieves
equal or better accuracy it will result
in more robust models to adversarial
attacks
it doesn't require any hyper parameter
tuning and I'm going to show extensive
testing on many different data sets and
models including imagenet which is a
very challenging classification problem
now stochastic gradient descent is the
defective method used for neural network
training the idea is that you have a
function f your neural network has
parameters W you have some input X and
it's a composite composition function of
some of our I from 1 to n your n
training examples and then the gradient
this stochastic gradient descent is that
you pick a random sample you compute the
gradient you descent along that
direction and you have the mini batch
gradient descent so now you know this is
very simple but there's a lot of
interesting things buried here so if our
function let's take a function a
function that looks like this first
let's take a water who thinks this is
the convex function I get different
results depending on the audience we
think this is non convex so if I take F
equals summit from i from 1 to n over 5
this is how it looks what if I take a
mini batch of it from 1 to B I look at
this who think that this is convex or
non convex who thinks it's non convex
who thinks it's convex it depends it
depends maybe the smaller size depending
on the Baxters if I use B equal m it's
obviously non convex but if B is small
maybe I just see this and I have no
problem getting stuck here here or here
and that's the problem with large by
size training if I use food-grade in the
center I start here I'll end up here but
if I do small SGD I will be able to
escape that but that's problematic
because we can do fast training so this
is a very nice visualization of how
neural network landscape looks like or
only in 2d it's a million I mentioned
problem but you can imagine that if I
start here I'll get stuck here if I
start here I'll get stuck in this local
minima and if this was the good local
minima I would never be able to get
there with full gradient descent however
this stuff works as you guys know this
is a work from our group for detecting
you know for putting bounding boxes
around objects for autonomous driving
this is another very challenging task
from Facebook instant segmentation it's
even hard for humans to do this and this
is an Oracle from from a group that does
medical imaging but the secret behind
all of these is that it requires massive
hyper primary tuning many times it
doesn't work and really have no idea
when it works and when it doesn't work
and so that's usually what's not sure
and if you do random search like this
you get lucky sometimes but there are
problems that's that's you won't be able
to solve where random search so we've
been able to solve the pong problem
you've seen this probably than the mario
with a in an area reinforcement learning
and then recently these paper from
google that eat the best go player in
the world
but what's not shown is that adversarial
examples can easily trick neural
networks so for example here is a
classification task of a strawberry
figure if you add imperceptible noise
for us people think that it's a toy pool
or buckeye you will think that again
it's a toy poodle
this is another work from my
collaborator crystal boly or interesting
work where basically this is the pong
game this screen is the neural network
that is able to win but if we inject
noise in every tenth frame only flip one
pixel you see that it loses the game so
it's not intelligent and I think one of
the main reasons is that we are doing
random search now there is many many
knobs as you know learning rate batch
size you know normal network
architecture and so we want to go to
large batch size but unfortunately large
batch size is interdependent with
degradation in accuracy it results in
poor generalization robustness of the
model depends on the backside you use
for training and the training time and
power scalability depends on batch size
so this is a work by yang Yu and
Berkeley when he was doing an internship
in a video that clearly shows the
problem so here we are looking at a plot
the y axis is the top one test accuracy
the x axis is the epochs of training
there's a blue curve shows the baseline
for alex net you see that it gets
roughly 57 percent accuracy on a
classification image if I use a larger
batch size 8192 you will see that we'll
have some performance gap it's five to
all the best one we don't know maybe 256
will perform there may be 1024 would
defective would behave differently the
reason we want to do large batch size is
because we can do more you know we can
exploit more power ISM and we can train
faster but this is completely
unacceptable that's a great point there
was actually a paper last year in nips
that said if you train longer this will
catch but that doesn't work for all
neural networks so there are many
counter examples they actually took Alex
net and showed that it works for Alex
and by offer from Technion but if you
take another know that for gresner it
doesn't work for that and that's one of
the problems in this field it works for
a subset of problems but then you go to
another one it doesn't work but that's a
great observation
now what no set of did this seminar work
very interesting paper in noisy LR 2016
where he conjectured that large
bite-size training his problem because
it gets attracted to sharp minimus it's
a very very contentious argument I'm on
the side of polluting this another
theory was that large batch has problem
because it gets at a stock inside point
but that's not necessarily true so what
was coconut sort of the idea let's
assume a very simple function a loss
function let's say 1d I start from here
I'll get stuck into this sharp minimum
if I use pool great in descent I start
from here I'll get stuck here but if my
testing loss is a little bit shifted
than my training my testing is a little
bit shifted than my training and I'm
stuck here
it's corresponds to a very bad point for
my testing but if I'm here it's shifted
it's fine it's a little bit off so I'll
still generalize very well this does not
necessarily have to be the case so
benjoe as a paper that shows that sharp
mini-mug can generalize well but in
practice this is a common thing that we
observe so we decided to Deep Diver the
deep dive here and we we need a tool the
tool is basically Hessian that's a tool
you know when when do you stop Michael
had a great topic yesterday where he
said you know you train until you get
tired well how do you know you've you've
converged to any meaningful point you
need to look at it through the lens of
the Hessian so we've developed a
framework this took a long time because
it's not easy to do this to back
propagate the hessian operator to deep
neural networks but we have that right
now and then when you have the session
operator you can take a look at the
curvature we know that the local minima
has positive curvature saddle point has
you know positive and negative so that
gives us a very nice tool to test where
where we are and then we visualize the
landscape of loss when we've converged
to a point so we took a neural network
alex net and we trained it for different
bag sizes so starting from batch size of
64 going all the way to the batches of
2048 and how do you visualize the lost
landscape that's that that was a
question that yes and one way is to look
at this first and second dominant eigen
vector of the Heche
so what we're doing here is we're
basically perturbing the laws along you
know if you're at W let's perturb it
along the first eigenvector and let's
put a bit along the second eigenvector
and then you plot it I think you agree
with me that large batch gets stuck in a
point that has much sharper curvature
and that's in line with most of those
results he used an approximate curvature
method this is the full Hessian back
propagated and this is the very first
work was another talk here that said we
cannot back propagate the Hessian but
that's not necessarily true so this is
what we've done you can now look at the
Hessian look at what's going on when you
converge that was the first two
directions what about the other
directions well we can visualize it but
we can look at a spectrum so here we are
looking at the eigenvalue of the hessian
and here is the number of the eigenvalue
as we go up the back size is increasing
so the orange pot shows bachelors of
2048 the red one is back size of 64 so
not only in the first and second
eigenvector you've converged to sharper
point but the first twenty and this is
the full hessian we can show all of it
because it's very computationally
expensive but the trend is quite clear
now what's going on during training
those large batch get stuck in style
points does it you know keep finding
sharp minimize so look at what's going
on during training the during training
we compute the first talking about
eigenvalue of the hessian and we log it
so 985 training you log how the
eigenvalue changes so for small bite
size you see that it starts to decrease
then there is a phase shift increases
again - very nice valley the gradient
decreases as well but if you look at
large bite size it's a full gradient
descent it's completely chaotic it
actually tries to find sharper and
sharper points in the optimization
landscape you look at the full gradient
is come it's very actually quite big so
it's not getting stuck inside points
it's actually finding sharper and
sharpen points it gets attracted to and
that makes sense intuitively from the
figure that i should the dotted plots
i'll talk about it so what we believe is
that you know the problem is that if
you're doing large backsides you get you
know in high dimension you get you know
you're zigzagging around points that
have very high curvature and that's the
problem
now we have the hessian so you know we
thought okay can be fixed this problem
now so i'm going to show you the details
of our method it's using kind of a
second order information to to choose
you know when when you're in these
problematic areas you can do a small
bite size that's the easiest where a
solution right around these problems
okay small bite size kind of sees a
convex problem well let's do small bite
size when you're here but when we get to
this nice flat region let's do large
batch service so that's the intuition
behind the method you can read our paper
for more details but the idea is that we
adaptively change learning rate and
batch size depending on the second order
and that that's very intuitive solution
it combines other things but before
going into the details of our method you
know there has been a lot of works that
showed things have nice properties but
it doesn't work for neuron that first so
let me actually show you a few results
first experiment is on cipher ten it has
ten classes five thousand examples per
class total of 50,000
raining examples and 10,000 testing
examples these are a few few cases does
it work here well let's let's look at
this table it's a very interesting table
you're showing batch size going from 128
to 16k and this is the baseline accuracy
you run with normal STD mini-batches TV
and you look at the accuracy 83% for 128
and when you go to 16 K degrades to 67%
you didn't change anything else the
number of updates is basically the
number of SGD updates you start from
35,000 iterations of SGD if you go to
larger batch size you only need 281
that's why we want to go to larger
batches
that's basically the motivation of
high-performance computing researchers
Facebook last year gave a you know
proposes a new solution by scaling
learning rate when you do large batch
size the solution is basically based on
approximating the lost function using
the first order Taylor series car
networks you know for small bite size
but when you go to large backside is it
completely diverges that doesn't work
but in that paper basically work only
for one neural network and ResNet 50 on
image net but it doesn't work for other
networks although later a couple months
later proposing a new solution works
very well consistent accuracy consistent
number of updates and we wanted to try
to see if we can use second order
information to get better performance
and this is the proposed solution
adaptive back size with adversarial
train which I'll explain the accuracy is
better the number of updates is 3x
better than Google only for this model
well maybe maybe yes shall we test it
another model this is white residual
Network it achieves better accuracy and
C 410 87% again works best in terms of
accuracy
number of updates against smaller than
Google well maybe it only works for
these two yesterday done another network
that we designed called squeeze next on
C 410 it achieves 92% accuracy it's
harder to Train does it work yeah we
didn't change any high performers
there's nothing you know sleep under the
rock here nothing changed from the
previous experiments to this one you
only ran that experiment
there's a couple cabinet so there is no
free lunch so you have to compute the
Hessian here and that's expensive so
there's some something here that I
haven't shown yet well explain how we
were dressed so there was a couple other
papers in 2013 very interesting work by
Yan Li kun no more pesky learning rate
that was tested on c4 and amnesty but it
didn't work on other datasets so we
decided to go further to find where we
prepared this method brakes look at
Street View house number this is a data
set designed by Andrew Aang's group at
Stanford 600,000 training examples
26,000 testing examples it's basically
images of house numbers you have two
detected this is four three five one
without changing anything we looked at
the Street View house number again
similar results again you go to larger
batch sizes this alex net the baseline
accuracy decreases from ninety four
percent to eighty four Facebook diverges
when you go to large batch size gogo has
kind of consistent accuracy but higher
number of updates if you do this
second-order type optimization that
versão
training better accuracy fewer number of
updates again without changing anything
as you increase the by service or
Facebook it does but not for ours
because we adaptively change bachelors
we don't necessarily increase the batch
size so what I'm reporting here with 131
K is not 131 K from the beginning it's
exactly the maximum great point I'll get
to that so the total grade it's kind of
correlated with the number of updates
because if I have enough parallel
processes I can distribute the work it's
not a one-to-one correspondence so
because we require hashing computation
that's something I haven't talked about
it doesn't come for free
so I'll talk about that but you know
when I talked to Michael last year you
know many people told us don't do second
order I talked to my mentor back in a
place that I didn't internship and he
told me that it's a higher exposure
don't do it because many people have
tried it but even in infinite number of
resources we now have a solution that
works but now I'll address how we reduce
that like do people ever just try chol
tried that before this and it's a very
extensive paper or why it fails and it
does fail actually for C for 10 you get
only 60% accuracy if you do say we trust
region with all the nicest nice things
and in a few months maybe we come back
and we kind of have some ideas of how to
fix that but there was a very extensive
study that Michael did that shows that
that actually fails and you finally test
that imagenet so this is the hardest
classification task and you know if
that's what usually works on the other
ones but doesn't work here this is the
1.2 million training examples 50,000
testing examples it consists of a
thousand classes some of them III don't
know you know for example different
types of dogs you know I tried to
educate myself is very hard to
determinate it's a very very challenging
task that Fei Fei Lee created this at
Stanford that kind of really pushed the
limits so we first looked at Alex and on
tiny image that this is a smaller data
set from image net and we looked at okay
let's see this is the famous Alex and in
2012 does it work here we expected it to
fail no we
you want did want to show a case that
our method fails because most care that
Michael always insists that we should
put limitations in the paper so we
looked at the baseline accuracy again
you see that 128 batch size 60% accuracy
goes all the way to 10% 10% and this is
what's not shown in a normal approach
this is typical you have to run a
gazillion runs you find the hyper
parameter that works best for that
minute for that model and that's it and
that's usually not shown so we looked at
our accuracy Absa method again
consistently better accuracy twice fewer
number of updates for Alex Minh and then
we looked at the most challenging neural
network resonant residual Network you
know I think this is the very first book
that has back propagated Hessian for
such a large data set on resonant again
no change in high parameters I'm not you
know putting anything there is no secret
here based on 70 point for validation
accuracy ABS a 70 point to 66 66 K
number of iterations the baseline could
support 50 K and the Google if you had
tested it it would have required 160k
SGD tration so roughly 2.5 x smaller
number of updates and what we're looking
here is basically the loss how does the
loss change as we go through the
training the blue curve is baseline the
red one is our proposed method accuracy
again you see that it follows the
baseline accuracy rate about is it
possible to get this gap fixed yeah if
you do hyper primary tuning what we
wanted to emphasize that you're not
changing anything in our method to
tailor it for a specific data set how
does it work back to a Hadees question
basically we look at the hessian and
based on the hessian if you're at a
point that has better curvature that
it's flatter nicer curvature we increase
spatulas laneway
otherwise we don't there's an adaptive
strategy and if you look at Google's
policy the Google tried too hard to tune
this so they increase the batch size on
30 bucks and 60 bucks and if you look at
the batch size this corresponds to very
nice phase transition in the second
information the Malon we found it but he
can automatically set this why looking
at second order information
she's quite interesting now there is
another thing called robust training I
don't think there is anything new here
Lauren del Valle did this work back in
97 I think there's a lot to learn from
there yeah I used to regularize against
sharp minimis a very interesting idea
and let's let's consider this case again
the sharp meenie miney moe usually we're
trying to drop this point to the lowest
value but if we were constrained to
dropping this disc I would never be able
to explore this one because I can't push
this game further down problem is this
is very expensive this food solving this
requires the second order it's a second
order conical programming program comes
with a problem but let's take a look a
little bit at robust optimization it's
really expensive they're simple linear
programming problem you want to find an
x such that the dot product defeat the
dot product between Z and X is minimized
but you have a constraint of ax less
than or equal to B so this is simple
linear programming problem but now I
assume that a b and c are uncertain I'm
not sure if a is really a maybe you can
talk trade by 10% and you is that I want
to find an X that's the solution to the
worst realization of a B and C so you
take the worst realization of a you
minimize with respect to that you get
the robust solution and so Lauren allowi
did a very seminal work in 97 that he
showed that actually this corresponds to
properly regularizing the problem so if
I solve this minimization problem this
is an l1 that Constantine karmanís did
at ut-austin
if I solve this problem usual
minimization problem properly regularize
it it's equivalent to the robust
optimization if my uncertainty is of
this one so if I'm not sure about K in
this form and I properly regularize X
then it's equivalent to that solution so
the last solution is equivalent to the
robust solution very interesting work
very similar work I kind of give credit
to them so we actually try to see if
this works were not a leopard
and we regularize against sharp mini-mug
and empirically we've seen that that
works the other problem is that you know
it's a very hard problem you know you
have to solve now I mean max problem so
the idea is that we perturb the input
being put under an uncertainty ball and
then we minimize not with the original
training examples but with some of them
being perturbed adversarially and
solving this maximization problem is
done using fast grading assignments that
by taking one grade in a sense will be
in a paper but the high level idea is
that basically we're taking the worst
possible X and we're minimizing with
respect to that instead of just me my
name is good and in last year a John
douches group in Stanford showed very
nice properties with this problem on you
know for comics problem that won the
best paper worried nips that they showed
that if you do a bust optimization you
not only reduce the bias term in the
error in the empirical risk minimization
but you also reduce the variance term
that's basically the idea so if I
usually do the SGD I'm only reducing the
average error and that's expected
because I'm always looking at the
average but if I do a bus optimization
also reduce the balance and so the
details of it is in their paper 44 pages
of the proof very interesting work and I
highly suggest take a look at that and
so we tested this to see if that works
in neural network we are approximately
solving this crude approximation if you
look at the case where we're doing full
gradient descent again we're looking at
lambda 1 the dominant eigen value of the
Hessian if you do robust optimization
you see that the lambda is smaller than
not doing robust optimization so it's
kind of regularizing you can start
minimize and so this is a component in
our our method we start with large
regularization and we decrease it so
this is my backbone is in image analysis
and that's what we do for example for
life so sometimes you start with high
regularization and we use it that's also
what we do in our missing
going back to hottest point this doesn't
come for free so hash and
backpropagation is expensive and it's
doesn't come for free so we actually
measured the time using they're not
highly optimized code that we developed
so we looked at there's three components
when you run this in parallel there is
computation time communication time and
of course the second order costs that
you have to take so the baseline every
tration requires 2 point 2 e minus 2
seconds the communication time is kind
of negligible and if you use ring
algorithm it will be independent of
number of processes that use and
baseline doesn't have any second order
cost the total training time for
imagenet resonating an image net will be
roughly 16,000 seconds 500 processes if
you use Google's policy you will be able
to reduce this by 2.7 X so you get to
6,000 seconds again you don't need any
second order information but if you use
our method it's an order of magnitude
costlier to compute Hessian you will
need 10 Hessian matrix to compute the
eigenvalues we use power iteration
roughly you require 10 iterations so
that multiplied by 10 will beat orders
of magnitude higher than computation
time and communication time but you
don't need to do that every tration so
we only do it at the very end of every
buck and one in fact for image that is 1
billion examples so it's not that often
and if you add up every number you end
up at 3400 seconds so 4.8 x fast this is
the best timing for image net no there
is not a work by consent that uses large
that they were able to Train image net
in 4 minutes but that requires a lot of
type of primary tuning so your rerunning
that problem may be a hundred times and
you're choosing the best so if you add
up all those numbers I think this will
be fast and then we have some proof for
conversions for complex problems that we
show that if your learning rate is
bounded by this licorice constant of the
gradient then basically you can show
that the error goes down up to a bias
and if learning rate goes to zero these
are all over vanish too and you will
converge to the global mean this is a
nice proof to have but you know there
has been a lot of messes that have shown
good results for comments problem
probably good results but doesn't work
on me a problem so if you
you can take a look at a paper for
details and then you know if that two
orders of magnitude is costly which I
agree it is costly then we explored
low-rank approximation to the Hessian we
explored block approximation to the
Hessian and we found that if you just
look at a few of the last layers of the
neural network that's enough to get
enough signal so if you look at
approximate Hessian this is the pool
hessian eigenvalues the green curve is
the approximate ation if you look at
just the approximate it's enough
empirically you don't have a proof for
it but empirically we saw that it's you
know I have a couple more slides about
you know robust optimization and white
works maybe I just show this one this is
basically again the spectrum of the
hessian after you've converged the first
20 eigenvalues if you do robust
optimization the spectrum will be nicer
and flatter so the values will be lower
and that's what we want and another very
important point about last papers award
was what we observed was you know you
kind of let me just go back to Michael's
point you you train until you get tired
and you think that you've converged to a
point maybe generalize as well but if
you look at pair sample I just take one
example from the training or testing and
I look at the Hessian eigen value what
does this correspond to having positive
and negative eigenvalues what does this
mean have I converged to local minima
definitely not is the saddle point maybe
if the gradient is small but if I look
at the full Hessian again
looks very nice location looks very nice
because again
Sgt minimizes the bias term and not the
variance but when I look at the pair
sample I haven't converged to anything
me so I would like to conclude you know
I think the only takeaway from from my
talk that I hope I have convinced you is
that second-order training would be the
de facto method going forward in a few
years it's possible to look at the
Hessian it's not that costly a little
bit more costly but it helps you not do
massive hyper primary tuning and going
forward I think this would be the de
facto method even though right now many
people feel like that it doesn't work
I'd like to conclude and thank my
collaborator especially Joao as well as
Michael and coracoid
and our sponsors thank you the spectrum
of power variation so we look at the be
care of the eigenvalue that the details
of the algorithm is in the paper but we
basically look at the how the eigenvalue
reduces so we look at the behavior of
the eigenvalue of the hessian we've
logged out of every at the end of every
epoch and then we're just learning rate
and by size based on that and also the
amount of robust optimization and
regularization will repeat into the
algorithm so it's an adaptive based on
second order information but we're still
doing STD so it's not full Newton's
method it's to SGD but we're working on
extending it to two minutes
[Applause]